اعين الجميع نحو جده السعوديه تزامنا مع
تواصل عمليات الاجلاء عبر مينائها يجري
طرف الصراع في السودان محادثات لاول مره
ترحب الرياض واشنطن وتعربان عن الامل في
الوصول لنهايه النزاع يحدد الجيش السوداني
شكل هذه المحادثات يقول ان الجلسات تبحث
فقط اليات تمديد الهدنه ولا تشمل اي اتفاق
نهائي لوقف اطلاق النار او قضايا سياسيه
اعين الاتحاد الافريقي على جده كذلك يقدم
الاتحاد الازمه الانسانيه امام الطرفين
داعيا لوقف القتال على وجه السرعه يتحرك
الامين العام للامم المتحده يصل الى
العاصمه الاثيوبيه ويلتقي رئيس الوزراء
ورئيس مفوضيه الاتحاد الافريقي يكشف مصدر
للجزيره ان الامم المتحده والاتحاد
الافريقي سيقدمان خارطه طريق لانهاء
الازمه يعرب غوتيريش من اديس ابابا عن
قلقه من تداعيات في السودان على المنطقه
وخاصه دول الجوار يصف غوتيرج هذه الدول
بالهشه وتلك الدول تستقبل وتصدر اللاجئين
بالملايين بسبب ازماتها الداخليه امنيا
وغذائيا اذ يستقبل السودان اكثر من مليون
لاجئ هربوا اليه من دول الجوار اثيوبيا
وجنوب السودان تحديدا اصبح السودان الان
يصدر اللاجئين الى هذه الدول ما يزيد من
الازمه الانسانيه في المنطقه ككل تتاثر
مصر فيتحرك وزير خارجيتها في جوله اقليميه
كذلك ولكن بعد ثلاثه اسابيع يتوجه سامح
شكري الى تشاد وجنوب السودان يبحث فيهما
عن حل للازمه هو الاخر استقبلت مصر عشرات
الالاف من اللاجئين السودانيين خلال
الاسابيع قليله الماضيه المسؤولون
المصريون قلقون على اقتصادهم المعتمد بشكل
كبير على السودان في لمحه سريعه على الامر
يش التبادل التجاريه بين مصر والسودان
اكثر من 13% من التبادل التجاري المصري مع
افريقيا مجتمعه رقم كبير يعكس الاعتماد
المصريه على جواره الجنوبي لا سيما في
الامن الغذائي اما الامن بمفهومه التقليدي
فيؤرق القاهره وهي تراقب حدودا تتجاوز الف
ومئتين كيلومتر قد تفتح على مصرعيها اذا
انهار النظام الامني في السودان بسبب
القتال التحركات الاخيره تاتي بعد تحركات
اقليميه اخرى لم تفضي الى نتائج عمليه
طرحت منظمه الايجاد الافريقيه مبادره للحل
وقررت افاده رؤساء كينيا وجنوب السودان
وجيبوتي بحثا عن ذلك الحل التزمنا ذلك مع
استعداد من جنوب السودان لاستضافه طرفي
الصراع لكن كل ذلك مره دون اثر لذلك يترقب
الجميع محادثات جده السودانيون ليسوا
وحدهم من ينتظر نهايه هذه الازمه